michael barone is a resident fellow at
the American Institute Enterprise
Institute senior political analyst for
the washington examiner Fox News
contributor and the principal co-author
of the Almanac of American politics he
has also served as a senior writer for
US News and World Report and as a member
of the Editorial Board of The Washington
Post a native of Michigan he graduated
from harvard university and yale law
school please join me in welcoming mr.
Barone
well thank you very much Kelly it's a
pleasure to be here as somebody grew up
in Michigan north of canada in my case I
said introduced myself with that and and
who attended to graduated from a college
whose first letter as H it's we're just
recovering from the election I think you
know one of the real anomalies this
election was that a country that it was
dissatisfied with performance of the
president that believed by fairly large
majorities the nation was not moving in
the right direction but it was pretty
clearly off on the wrong track turned
around and reelected the president it
produced a slightly larger margin for
the majority's democratic party in the
Senate and it elected again a Republican
House so I think that's interesting the
status quo got endorsed even as people
expressed dissatisfaction Barack Obama
won a second term by a margin current as
current returns are in indicating by
52-48 percent pasta that may turn out to
be 51 to forty-eight percent when
California and other states finally
finished their counting four years ago
California took five weeks to count the
presidential vote in Brazil they managed
to do it in five hours off some pretty
rugged terrain for some reason it seems
to take California a long time they're
probably the public employees they are
probably spending time calculating their
pensions and how they're going to live
high on the hog you know in retirement
early retirement but it may go up to
fifty one forty eight percent that we'll
see he appears to have on the electoral
vote by a wide margin 332 electoral
votes to 206 that's assuming Florida
goes for
goes for Obama he's ahead and returns
currently and they're still counting as
I understand in miami-dade county
without the assistance of quite as many
lawyers for both parties as were present
at the counts in two thousand since it
doesn't make a difference in terms of
the result it's interesting that's kind
of a huge electoral vote hall for a
relatively narrow victory in jimmy
carter won by fifty two forty eight
percent the same margin that's currently
on the board for obama and he got only
297 electoral votes just 27 more than he
needed if you go to 2000 for george w
bush won by 51 248 margin and he got 286
it seems to me as i reflect on these
elections that the Electoral College
seems to give the Democratic Party a
certain structural advantage and I wrote
a column on this partially on this
subject that appears in today's Wall
Street Journal Obama got landslide
victories is defined them as fifty-seven
percent of the popular vote or more in
11 states in the District of Columbia
which have a hundred and sixty-three
electoral votes that's basically those
are basically states that in this
divided country Democrats don't have to
worry about in the presidential race
Mitt Romney won thirteen states by such
landslide margins but those thirteen
states have only 104 electoral votes
they're mostly pretty small states the
single exception being Texas the second
largest state Republicans basically
don't have to worry about those states
but they have to to get to 270 from 104
you need 166 electoral votes to get from
two to 74 for the Democrats from there
163 you only need 107 so the Democrats
have more hunting ground to go after
those votes many times during this
campaign people were comparing this
election with 2004 and there's certain
obvious comparisons you have an
incumbent president running for
re-election
you have a challenger who is a rich guy
from Massachusetts in Mitt Romney's case
he made his money in John Kerry's case
he he married it the and in a candidate
in both cases whom some people
characterized and the opposition
characterized as kind of out of touch
with the ordinary person but there's a
big one big difference between this in
2004 in 2004 turn out was vastly
increased both the Bush and Carrie
campaigns said that they that they were
not so much seeking underweight
undecided voters but to get their voters
out to vote on Karl Rove Bush's
strategist famously said that there will
be seven percent of the electorate was
movable voters and it was more important
to concentrate on organization that's
what the Bush campaign did it's also
what the kerry campaign did and they had
great success but also you know the
increase in turn out in some part
obviously is due to spontaneous reaction
of american voters turn out went up from
105 million in 2002 122 million in 2004
that's a substantial increase this time
it seems to be different the turnout in
2008 was 231 million 130 excuse me 131
million / 122 not as big an increase
from old forests for the previous four
years as we had in 2004 but nonetheless
an increase right now I think the latest
counts have about a hundred and
twenty-two million votes tallied while
they dawdle over the results in
Sacramento it looks like it's going to
end up being about to 129 million we're
not sure that's that would be a decline
from 131 million 2004 seems to have been
affirmative feeling for both sides and I
think and in that issue i think really
non-economic issues were of primary
importance you had the iraq war war and
peace issues and you had cultural issues
the you know the demographic variable
most highly correlated with voting
behavior
is religion or degree of religiosity
within each sectarian group with the
more religious devoted voting reporting
to vote Republican the more secular or
less religiously motivated tending to
vote Democratic that those cultural
issues as I called them seemed to evoke
large turnout this year the focus was
more on economics the voting blocs of
the two parties still reflect those
religious divisions but with some
changes in some differences in some
people being willing to cross the line
for the Democrats in two thousand six
and two thousand eight for the
Republicans in 2010 the this election
the turnout was down and in this way it
resembles the election of 1996 another
reelection election in which turnout was
also down from 104 million in 92 when
some of that was generated by ross perot
and down to 96 million in in 1996 this
is in another respect also but so this
was more like 1996 that was more of a
time of economic contentment this is
more of a time of economic discontent
but it's the you see that same feature
turnout going down the economic issues
don't seem to generate as much turnout
with an electorate among electoral
blocks whose which are tend to be
defined by their attitudes on cultural
issues there's one difference however
between 1996 in 2012 and that is this
when bill clinton was reelected he
increased his margin as in fact
increased his percentage margin as every
reelected president has since accepted
since woodrow wilson in 1916 when his
percentage margin over the his chief
opponent was was much smaller than it
had been four years before clinton got
forty nine percent of the vote if you
split the ross perot vote according
what those voters indicated was their
second preference Clinton would have
been up to about 51 or 52 percent of the
vote and so forth in 2004 also George W
Bush increased his percentage of the
vote from forty-eight percent in 2002
51% of 2004 Oh Barack Obama declined in
percentage from fifty three percent 250
or perhaps 51 when the votes are counted
all the votes are counted his victory
was a victory in some respects for big
government policies we've had a vast
expansion of the size and scope of
government and the president was
reelected Obamacare will not be repealed
it and it will not come to repeal of
Obamacare which the Republicans called
for will not come to a vote in a
Democratic Senate at the same time the
and Democrats will have considerable say
over what kind of fiscal policy we're
going to have because of the president's
reelection but i don't think you can
count it as a victory or at least you
can't count it entirely as a victory for
big government ideas bill clinton's
reelection was not a victory for big
government ideas after his party lost
majorities in both houses of Congress in
1994 he pivoted to the center or at
least said he did most voters believe he
did I think I think that argument is
correct and he was reelected with a
larger percentage Barack Obama decided
not to pivot in response to the
Republican victory in the house and
capture gaining 63 seats in the House of
Representatives in 2010 he decided to
stick with his policies and to write y
and it turned out to run an essentially
negative campaign it wasn't my judgment
a weak field of candidates in which I
would argue that MIT Romney was probably
the only one capable of winning a
presidential election I think the others
would have been disqualified in some
respect and in fact Romney
was disqualified as it turns out by the
negative campaign that they ran against
it they in particular you know they ran
it you know he shipped jobs to China he
did this he gave my wife cancer etc etc
in the Obama campaign and its allies but
primarily the Obama campaign ran early
and often used the financial advantage
that they had starting in April and up
through the party conventions at the end
of the August beginning of September and
they spent about half that money on what
I call a three-state electoral vote
firewall I mean if you rank the states
in 2008 according to ascending
percentage of Obama percentage of the
total vote he won the three he want
electoral votes in Indiana North
Carolina in the second congressional
district of Nebraska by one vote they
they didn't firewall those they spent
the big amount of their money on the
states of Florida Ohio and Virginia
which are the next three states in the
Obama order Obama got great better than
his national percentage in every other
state that he carried and basically
those three states have us have sixty
electoral votes and their calculation
was that look if we hold these three
states and all the others we that where
we got higher percentages will have 332
electoral votes way over 270 that you
need to win the presidency so we're not
you know if we hold those we can lose a
few of those other states and it won't
really matter the on the other hand if
they lost those three states they would
be down to 272 and a loss in any other
state would have resulted in the
president's defeat the firewall seem to
be working if you look at the data up
through and after both party conventions
and until the first debate on October
third then it became apparent that that
Mitt Romney was making gains he was
ahead or even in many of the
presidential polls and he was clearly
making gains in Florida virgin
and to a lehtonen in Ohio where those
ads also included the headline that the
New York Times report editor placed on
romney's opinion article let Detroit go
bankrupt in which Romney actually
suggested a government guarantee of
debtor-in-possession financing through a
bankruptcy procedure which was in fact
what the Obama administration did plot
but Romney was not in favor of the
political payoff that they gave to the
United Auto Workers in the process of
doing that so I think that was
misleading I think looking back senator
rob portman of Ohio advised Romney to to
make a concerted argument for his
explaining his position on the auto
bailout the Romney campaign did not take
that advice in retrospect that seems to
have been a mistake basically the Obama
people carried according to current
returns those three states Florida Ohio
and Virginia by about 250,000 votes
that's zero point one nine percent of
the total votes cast around the country
or figure there abouts he got 50 50 and
51 percent in those states but he got
those 60 electoral votes and he he won
the election in addition he managed to
carry all of his other states if you
compare from current returns the
movement in the eighth largest target
states Colorado Florida Iowa Nevada and
New Hampshire North Carolina how
Virginia incomparable percentage 2008
Obama percentage 2012 what you see is
that it declines by 1.5% if you take the
rest of the country it declines by two
point eight percent that's a significant
difference in my judgment a two point
eight percent decline everywhere would
have elected obama but barely and with
not a large margin in the electoral
college but that's basically the
salt the obama organization did indeed
turn out its voters very able e
examination of the county returns
suggests to me that they did a good job
of turning out black voters in central
cities and rural counties in virginia
north carolina and florida they did a
good job of carrying hispanic voters and
indeed carried has it's one demographic
group in which they did better than they
did in 2008 with obama carrying
hispanics according to the exit poll by
71 to 27 a wide margin among a group
that is going to be at least somewhat
larger a percentage of the electorate in
future elections sooner or later i don't
think they did as well looking at those
county returns on university vote and
young people vote the exit poll showed
obama carrying young people 6632 in 2008
the current one is 6237 that's that is
some significant difference in 2008
those 30 and over voted for obama by a
52-49 margin which prompted me to make
the comment that the republican to avoid
defeat them the republicans should have
passed a constitutional amendment
raising the voting age to 35 the this
time obama did not care by my
calculations off the exit poll obama did
not carry 30 and overs his margin among
the millennials was large enough to give
him that 5248 popular vote or maybe
51-48 nationally but i think that that's
if obama's victory was not a positive
endorsement of big government ideas i
think the results in the elections for
house of representatives was was not a
rejection of those of the ideas of those
who oppose big government and want to
shift us back to our historic percentage
of government as a percentage of gdp
from the much higher levels that we've
achieved in the last four years the
republicans carried
the House of Representatives the current
count it appears that they lost a net of
of seven seats going from 242 which they
had after the 2010 election to 235 which
is the highest they got during the newt
gingrich and dennis hastert speaker
ships i think that that's a significant
victory whose meaning has been largely
overlooked in my wall street journal
article this morning i started off by
noting that i was in the room with the
fox news decision desk in New York and
one of the guys that was following the
house fold said well there's a
statistical model from the exit poll
people about how many House seats are
going to change based on house results
and he says the model shows with
considerable time that the Republicans
are going to retain a majority in the
house they basically give you a range of
outcomes and if you're satisfied that
they're going to get the 218 majority if
the model says they're definitely going
to get that you know if the model says
you're looking at to 32 to 40 if you can
call the election and the head of the
decision death said now are you sure
about that and he said yeah he said okay
God on the phone he said Fox News is
called that the Republicans will win a
majority in the house that was then
mentioned by the announcer and everybody
went back to the presidential election
none of us spent any more time thinking
about the House of Representatives but
the fact is and voters and television
viewers didn't losing just seven seats
is a considerable achievement it's not
one that I would have predicted with
great confidence if i knew obama was
going to have popular vote majority and
a win the that's despite the fact that
republicans lost five seats to
redistricting to democratic
redistricting plans in illinois and five
seats in to redistricting plans in
democratic redistricting plans in
california california had a technically
nonpartisan Commission but the Democrats
gamed the system and got their moles on
it and produce plans that help them
unseat some of the Republicans that's
you know despite those
was another such instance in one seat of
Maryland despite those losses they kept
their net losses down to seven with and
I should add that Republicans where they
were in control of redistricting good a
good job of protecting their 2010
freshmen and other members that were
weak I think that's an interesting thing
there's a contrast with 96 here in 96
Clinton increased his percentages and
Republicans came close to losing a
majority in the house this year Obama's
percentage went down and Republicans
held a workable majority in the house I
think that one of the things obviously
that we're going to be looking at now is
our fiscal issues tax reform the fiscal
cliff the debt ceiling these things are
forcing action and I would maintain that
they're forcing action in a way that
works against the big government goals
of the Obama administration and of the
majority party Democrats in the Senate
and works towards their what the
Republicans in the House the kind of
goals that they want to see achieved the
the you know I don't know how these
negotiations will go one conservative
writer said if Obama's reelected the one
person I wouldn't on earth I would not
want to be as Speaker John Boehner he's
got a caucus made up or a contra
publican conference where an awful lot
of the members are new members where
they came to Washington determined to
vote against you know the promise to
vote against raising the debt ceiling
etc etc it's going to be hard to sell
any kind of budget deal i'm at American
Enterprise Institute I've been working
on something I call an e-book that
basically and the titan tentative title
of which is can the government be rolled
back we're going to put it online the
first week in december and it takes a
look of instances in american history
where voters have repudiated or have
arguably repudiated big government
policies and it looked at what happened
next were the people installed with
majorities able to roll back a
government and it looks at what happened
after the election of 1920 1938 1946
1966 1980 1994 and the answer is a mixed
answer sometimes there's very effective
rollback of government not totally and
you know government grows most in the
war in war times in our two world wars
but there is a rollback of big
government policies in some effective
way in the 1920s after the 1946 election
after the 1980 election after the 1994
election and it was done both in 19th
after for 1946 and after 1994 when you
had a Republican House in those cases
Republicans in control of both houses i
should say in control of the house and a
majority in the senate because nobody
entirely controls the Senate and they
did that you know for operating from the
legislative branch with all the tactical
disadvantages that has these things are
possible to do those who seek rollback
don't get everything they want and but
they can get some important things and I
think that's one lesson that the House
Republicans need to keep in mind voters
in there that is in what they may regard
as their unwisdom did not give you the
Senate and the presidency you you're not
going to have the presidency for the
next four years you needn't faces severe
fiscal problems with clothes in
deadlines you need to get the best deal
that you can it seems you know Speaker
Boehner did talk about increasing
revenues but not increasing tax rates
that will be something House Republicans
will want him to continue to insist on
and it is echoing there what Mitt Romney
said what the various Republicans on the
Super
committee in the gang of eight have
accepted revenues are running low but
they should also keep in mind what
history tells us and what Mitt Romney
said in one of the debates one way to
raise revenues is have vibrant economic
growth that's the lesson from the deals
that Newt Gingrich and Bill Clinton made
in 1995-96 and again in 1997 when the
Republicans got a tax capital gains tax
cut but as part of a package that then
installed the S chip children's health
care program they they gave up on one
thing in order to get something else
when you get vibrant economic growth
revenues pour in at rates I'm not
projected by either the congressional
budget office or the office of
management and budget that's a lesson I
think they need to keep in mind let me
conclude by making some sort of
political science ii observations that
are prompted by this election in the
early 1990s in 1990 the political
scientist and political pundits had it
as gospel that the republicans had a
lock on the presidency the democrats had
a lock on the House of Representatives
and they gave reasons why this was and
in fact the Democrats had controlled the
house of representatives at that point
for 36 years the republicans won four of
the five presidential elections between
nineteen sixty eight and nineteen eighty
eight so there were off facts seem to
suggest that and they had these
structural reasons why this was so one
would always be so and so forth and so
on well the Democrats broke the lock on
the presidency in 1992 the Republicans
broke the lock I'm a house in 1994
starting with those elections Democrats
have one for the six presidential
elections they want a plurality of the
popular vote and one other but also
starting in nineteen ninety four
Republicans have one can polo the house
of representatives in eight out of ten
elections it's starting to look like
there may be something structural in
that and I think there is and part of
the structural reason
demographics if you look at where voters
are physically Democratic voters tend to
be clustered the most heavily Democratic
groups blacks Hispanics what the
demographer joel kotkin calls gentry
liberals think upper east side of
manhattan san francisco it's a
montgomery county maryland the they tend
to be very clustered in certain parts of
very large metropolitan areas some
extent university towns they and what
they do i think is they help democrats
nail down electoral votes in several
large and medium-sized states that's
that electoral vote block I talked to
you about with a hundred and sixty-three
electoral votes landslide states for
Barack Obama and you can make similar
analysis of previous elections that I
think I haven't done all the
calculations recently but we show
something similar that helps Democrats
in the electoral college where we have
the unequally sighs States each carried
by a block I mean if you took
California's Central Valley and made it
a separate state it would have about 16
electoral votes and it would be a target
state I might even be in some elections
a safe Republican state but it's part of
California so it doesn't matter how
people vote there California is 55
electoral votes at current levels seem
to be going safely Democratic so
Democrats have more happy hunting
grounds for electoral votes with that
big electoral vote block because of the
concentration of voters there that
concentration however works against
Democrats and for Republicans I'm
arguing in when you've got equal
population congressional districts in
you know congressional districts within
a state have equal populations and you
know while some of the smaller states is
a little unequal basically there's 435
similar sized units because Democrats
are constantly being concentrated in
those neighborhoods don't affect many
districts in 2008 barack obama carried
28 congressional
districts with 80 or more percent of the
vote democrats could have used some of
those eighty percent in some other
districts which they carried this trend
is also exacerbated by the prevailing
interpretation of the Voting Rights Act
John McCain Cade carried zero
congressional districts with eighty
percent I think when we get round to the
presidential vote by CD which nobody i
know is calculating right now obama will
have carried about the same number of
districts john kerry carried i think
twenty congressional districts as they
were then configured with eighty percent
or more of the vote i think that obama
will carry some number like that 2028
romney will carry eighty percent maybe
in one or two districts in Utah which is
the state with the biggest Republican
percentage increase compared to 2008 you
will not be surprised to learn that's
basically I think it may be time for the
political scientists and US political
pundits to come up with a new rule about
which party has a structural advantage
in which set of elections and that's the
one and we better do so before that rule
becomes obsolete like the old rule
became obsolete in the 1990s thank you
very much and what's we're going to
invite you to have questions with Mike's
around
okay I'm told we're supposed to wait for
microphones here yeah if you just oh if
you just wait for us to come to you and
wait we help you why don't you give the
mic to that guy and then you come around
here and she'll be next please tell me
where you're from always like to know
where you grew up and stuff oh okay well
well you know I described how our
electoral blocks particularly in the
decade past but still to a considerable
extent are you know defined by positions
on cultural issues that continues to be
the case and in fact I think it's
ordinarily it's the case ordinarily in
American history my book our country the
shaping of America from Roosevelt to
Reagan which David was kind enough to
mention his and by the way you can get
it I last time I checked on Amazon you
could get a copy for 11 cents the I made
that argument and I think the argument I
continue to hold to it we have tended
there's a book by a journalist named
bill Bishop I'll called the big sort
which he points out that we are you know
there are fewer clothes States than
there were in 1976 now 76 is an extreme
example of many clothes states because
what was happening is that both
political parties nominated somebody
from their historic heartland Jimmy
Carter from South Georgia Gerald Ford
from out state-michigan when that
Heartland was in the process of moving
from its historic allegiance toward the
other party most noticeably with the
white Southerners but also to some
extent that northern tier of states and
so there were cross pressures and that
made a lot of states close I mean the
San Francisco Bay Area in
six voted for Carter by margin of 51 to
49 percent when Republicans win 51 /
forty-nine percent you know in the Bay
Area again we will be something really
cataclysmic happened to the Democratic
Party okay and I think you know
Americans with choices affluent people
professionals and so forth increasingly
choose to live in communities or
metropolitan areas neighborhoods that
are culturally congenial and that's what
you know free peoples do sometimes I
think ultimately it's an argument for
limited government I mean we hear that
America is suddenly diverse it never has
been that's not true during most of our
history we have been culturally diverse
since colonial days and the founders
recognized that and they said when they
came to making the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights they said look we're
going to have a limited federal
government because if you get too
involved to have federal government
making all the decisions centralized
decisions it's going to be a problem in
a culturally diverse country they said
in the first amendment the Congress
shall make no law regarding an
establishment of religion or respecting
an establishment of religion that is the
federal government was going to be
neutral I'm religions States then were
debating whether or not to disestablish
their established churches and some of
them were the established church mean to
maintain in Connecticut till 18 18 and
in Massachusetts till 1833 we said we're
going to be neutral on religion and
we're not going to prohibit but we won't
let anybody prohibit the free exercise
thereof that formula mostly worked
although not always we had a civil war
because a federal issue arose about
slavery in the territories and it's a
lesser than I think Hillsdale people
learn about very seriously and you had
take a position one way or the other on
that and we had a civil war but mostly
that position is work I think it is
harder to have big government have
cultural diversity is more difficult to
handle when you have big government here
Kathleen Sebelius and Barack Obama
decided the Catholic organizations like
flick charities have to provide
insurance which gives you no payment for
contraceptives with no co-payment by the
insured that's an issue that we've
always handled at other levels in our
country we've handled a lot of issues
with states localities and voluntary
associations like Catholic Charities
which do a lot of the work of society
people acting together now we've have
one person making that decision and it's
a problem white catholics by the way
vote of 5935 for mitt romney that's the
highest percentage probably that
republican candidate has ever gotten
from white catholics an interesting side
note to the election and it's reflective
i think in part on that issue and you
know those those when you have big
government those issues will continue to
arise even over something that you can
obtain for nine dollars a month at
Walmart which is you know cost less than
two pumpkin lattes at Starbucks so here
we are yes ma'am where are you from
Kathy hargett from the People's Republic
of Montgomery County Maryland okay
where'd you grow up uh since six years
old I was there since 6 i'm a
naturalized citizen i wasn't born in all
states and my question is we we don't
have a lot of people real happy today
but we have some people real happy oh
yeah we we being the people in this room
and others who share our politics and
one thing we were told I was attended a
meeting yesterday where Jim Nicholson
spoke and and he told us to look forward
to the tooth the 2014 Senate elections
and so I would like to hear he didn't go
into any detail but I would like to hear
what you might expect we might possibly
gain in the 2014 Senate elections I
wouldn't count on a lot i'll tell you
why republicans had reason to look
forward to the 2012 senate elections 23
democratic seats up only 10 republican
seats up it looked like a sure chance
for republican gains
a good possibility of gaining four seats
that were given the majority leadership
even if barack obama was reelected well
hoppin republicans lost two seeds net
you know in a year of tremendous
opportunity and i think one reason is
bad candidates I mean you know that I've
analogized the Tea Party movement large
movement of people into politics to
characterized by it with the peace
movement of 40 years before you get some
you know it brings some talented
political people into politics think of
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson for
example but it also brings some wackos
and weirdos in witches and we put too
many of them on the ticket why the
Senate candidates in in Missouri and
Indiana felt obliged to talk about
abortion in the case of rape nobody's
advocating such legislation it's
unconstitutional under current judicial
rulings it's not a serious issue you
should brush it aside as a hypothetical
that doesn't matter George
Stephanopoulos will try to get you to
say whether or not you want to ban
contraceptives George that's been
illegal under Supreme Court doctrine
says for 47 years you know that's the
answer you know the press you know the
Constitution is wisdom guarantees is a
free press but not a fair one and
Republicans need to learn to have
candidates that don't make unforced
errors if I went back a few years ago
and did an article about you know which
party has lost most Senate seats I
unforced errors and guess which one
don't nominate dogs okay you know Tea
Party folk like the peace movement folk
want to nominate the most purest
candidate I think it's time now that
basically legislative decisions are
being forced on us now by deadlines by
economic pressures I wouldn't wait to be
bailed out by Senate races I wouldn't
wait to be bailed out by the next
presidential race I would be trying to
use the leverage that Republicans have
in the house of representatives to get
as good a deal as we want because the
the facts of the issues work in the
direction against big government that's
what Republicans have going for them the
house control that and they have one
more thing governorships and states you
know scott walker in wisconsin bob
mcdonnell in virginia there Chris
Christian in New Jersey there are many
examples reform and people that are
dedicated to constitutional politics
should remember that many decisions are
led to the states we've had great
conservative victories and public policy
on welfare and climb control they were
pioneered in the states in the cities by
people like tommy Thompson with 70
should not have come back and run for
the Senate and people like Rudy Giuliani
in New York City and then they were
copied around the country other
republicans picked them up some
democrats did to you had democratic
governors who passed this on welfare
reform measures and it finally became a
federal issue and bill clinton felt
obliged to sign up for reelection up
felt obliged to sign public policy
successes can percolate up from states
and localities so people that are
interested in that you know you're not
going to pass what you want in Congress
entirely except as dire circumstances
force you in the house republican
bargaining skill Speaker Boehner is
bargaining skill gets you there but you
have the possibility of making public
policy successes in other places and
with voluntary associations so you know
you never have final victories in public
policy sometimes you have what enduring
successes welfare reform has been an
enduring success now for a generation
and not all successes endure forever but
some of them like the taft-hartley labor
law passed after that 1946 rollback folk
has lasted three generations that's not
bad for Public Policy let's go for
another question we got somebody over
here hi this horn yeah hi i'm linda
lewis i was born in john bainer district
in butler county
oh well the gay Hamilton Middletown way
east of Hamilton south of middle yeah
that Cincinnati accent actually um west
chester ohio is where i went to school
which is where he is like you're chilly
huh I like three ways ways okay and
usually we get skyline chili when we're
down there and now we live in haymarket
Virginia okay you talk about the
structural use of the House of
Representatives and I wonder though how
how much it really can be utilized with
this administration with a president who
seems to feel it's fine to just dictate
things he can't get through the Congress
well that's amazing and again with the
state's I think it's great we have 30
governors but I wonder things in the
states that conflict with federal law it
seems like it's if they like it in the
White House then the state is irrelevant
but now what's going to happen with this
marijuana thing that's a state federal
issue to now with with the Colorado and
Washington so I really wonder how much
Rick Perry said it was okay with him in
those states he had three reasons
because well I'm waiting for the trial
look I'm waiting for the trial whole
years to come up with the the health
effects of smoking marijuana I want to
see if they prosecute that the way they
did well be back you know the answer
your question is you don't achieve full
success we live in a two-party country
most of us if we really think about it
would not want to live in a country
where one party wins all the elections
you tend to get corruption you tend to
get cronyism you tend to get a lot of
bad things but we always hate it when
our side loses and or usually do but
that's a consequence of living in an
electoral democracy you don't win them
all and you don't win all policy fights
and you don't win them at all levels but
you can choose to keep on fighting
you can choose to you know go to
Colorado and test that marijuana law
let's go back here my name is Jordan
gerke I grew up in Dave camps fourth
congressional district back in Michigan
I had two questions for you first first
one is with due respect do you think
maybe you're being a little hard on the
Tea Party blaming them for the loss of
the Senate if you look down the list you
can also say yeah I mean Aiken and
Murdock I'll totally concede to you but
you look at Florida with Mac you look at
Montana with ree Berg you look at you
Rick Berg and North Dakota the NRSC got
their man and every single one of those
instances and they were all they all ran
bad campaigns and they all lost so is it
isn't it more fair to say that there's
plenty of blame to go around for losing
the Senate the Steiners blame to go
around but basically you know we lost
for sure Senate seats in the last two
cycles in Missouri Indiana Nevada and
Delaware by unfortunate choice of
candidates right in addition if there
had not been Tea Party challengers to
Olympia Snowe in a state that Mitt
Romney ended up getting forty percent of
the vote in would she have decided to
retire well if not you know olympia
snowe is not perfect from a conservative
point of view but she probably going to
be better than angus King and you and
you would have you take those five seats
and you you know if you'd have Mitt
Romney had won the election Harry Reid
would not be majority leader anymore so
you know there's always this Tennessee I
saw it in the peace movement that you
know we want the purest candidate you
need to distinguish between purist
candidates that have the political and
policy judgment of Iran Johnson and
those who have the political instincts
and policy judgment of Richard Mourdock
sorry but that's life booting seats and
safe States is real dumb yes sir hi I'm
Mike bergedy from Front Royal Virginia
where 75 miles west of washington DC
warren county warren county and we have
the headmaster and a number of students
from chelsea academy here today so
they're very interested in
what you're talking about my personal
question is this how my Obama be in a
pinch book president I don't see it you
know i think i've written columns about
how I think he's flautas the law in some
cases by recess appointments for example
that's being challenged in court because
a lot of people are affected by the
regulations that that consumer finance
board makes so as the lady was saying
yeah you fight some of these battles in
court but I think that no I think
impeachment would be a very bad idea
look we went through that with Bill
Clinton didn't we and I think you had a
very unfortunate situation there because
there were two arguments you could make
about the impeachment of Bill Clinton
and the Democrats and which I think
reasonable people could believe and the
Democrats all chose the argument that
would result in his not being removed
from office and the Republicans almost
all of them chose the argument that that
would make him be removed from office
the arguments were you know whatever his
transgression it's a matter involving
personal life and simply does it impact
on him as a public policy maker actually
it did but I'll get to that minute but
you know it's a personal transgression
the Republican argument was lying under
oath is a felony the president takes an
oath they take care of laws be
faithfully executed that is inconsistent
with the commission of a felony
basically I think what the American
people said is that we believe in the
22nd amendment the 22nd amendment is the
amendment limiting presidents to two
terms we elected this guy to two terms
we want him to stay in office for two
terms we would not actually although he
thinks so elect him to a third term if
he could try for it and did but we want
him to serve out his second term I think
that's what they said and you know we
had an election our guy had a chance to
win he didn't so I would not be even
talking about impeachment you know you
can talk about him flouting federal law
in a variety of areas as I have as
George will has as other people have but
I don't see impeachable offenses let's
go one more question there thank you I'm
been cold with the American Energy
Alliance I grew up in longview texas and
the what was at the time longview gregg
county in that I gregg county there 154
counties in Texas yeah exactly exactly
so here's my question i looked at the
ohio map for the presidential race at
the precinct level for the senate race
and for the house races and it was very
very telling that barack obama actually
lost precincts that sherrod brown one
and if you looked in at the
congressional races there's just these
narrow little slivers of blew up along
the up along the lake and everything
else in ohio is red at the at the
district at the district level sherrod
Brown well how do you make it the
sherrod Brown actually won precincts
that Barack Obama lost so there are
people that voted for Mitt Romney and
sherrod Brown and if the United Auto
Workers and the bailout thing was the
issue it just seems that shared Browns
the biggest labor organizer in the
Senate that it seems like he would be
able to actually turn out some votes is
that do you think that had some actually
i think you know i'd have to check the
numbers right now but my impression i
think we're more of a straight ticket
nation that we used to be we really
changed in that respect in the mid-90s
when these party blocks became
solidified along the demographic lines
that i mentioned i think that the not
that many people split their tickets I
mean sherrod Brown was the incumbent
senator he was better known i can see
somebody working a blue-collar guy
working in a coal related business that
says well i'm going to vote for mitt
romney but sherrod Brown is always with
working man that's plausible as for the
congressional district map you know that
was designed by Republicans to produce a
Republican result okay let's you know
let's not take the untenable position
that gerrymandering is only a democratic
practice okay the so you know that's not
we have one close race that new 13th
district Jim Renacci versus Betty Sutton
with the Republican one which is sort of
a hardening thing one thing that struck
me
as I've looked through as I was looking
through the county returns on election
night I really expected and I wrote that
I expected to see in Ohio for example
but I saw in 2004 which was an election
night as County returns came in and he
got one hundred percent or nearly one
hundred percent in the county in the
smaller counties which usually report
earlier I saw increase in turn out
increase in bush percentage that
represented the sort of positive feeling
for bush it represented the Bush
campaign organizational efforts I
expected and hoped I confess to see the
same pattern in Ohio I didn't it's I
expected to see affluent voters counties
swing more to Mitt Romney as compared to
McCain or something that I did not a lot
of evidence that that I mean you
basically you know you start making
county maps and put the swing number in
and it looks like to in a lot of places
it looks rather similar I'm not sure
what to make of this but I think in the
target States at least the this
electorate look very much like the
electorate of 2008 except smaller so I'm
still thinking about what that means you
know I so I'm I'll depart with those
words I'm still thinking about it and
those of you you know you know we don't
want one party to win all elections we
do want to work for good public policy
there is reason to keep fighting there
is warrant to say that there is some
mandate on the side of curbing big
government in the house elections this
was a closely divided election we're not
we're talking about a big margin in the
electoral college but a small margin in
the popular vote and the popular vote
for the house will probably turn out to
be about fifty forty eight Republicans
so there's reason for disappointment but
not despair thank you very much